the Joe Rogan experience you know girls
getting butt cancer now are they really
from shake butts I didn't know that yeah
I know I know some botched
butt cancer yeah yeah they were the one
that I was watching a clip off a botched
the other day this girl had a fake butt
and they were just trying to fix it
and it's just this disaster this poor
lady it was just it's just like the
surface of the Moon was just all dented
in [ __ ] up and you know what it is
it's the Kardashians man they ruined it
it's well I think it's I think it's
every every generation or even century
you can go back to the old days where
the most of the the body that's hardest
to get is the most popular body Kings
were fat because they had a lot of food
right peasants weren't but they wanted
to be fat right because it showed a sign
of money yes and then it was I believe
the 50s it was all about rail-thin no
but no boobs just rail and then because
that was hard to obtain
you know because most people aren't born
like that now the Kardashians it takes
money I guess for a lot of women to
achieve that and money in money the
amount of money where you don't have the
disposable income to do it right so not
a lot of people can do it so it seems
like the most popular body for women is
the body's the hardest to obtain it's
never like a normal body is beautiful
it's always like no we need very large
butts well it's also what you see in
media right that's why a lot of women
thought that it would be really good to
be real thin because they saw models
because designers closing clothing
designers like models to be real thin
because then they're like a hanger like
there's no weird big tits and big ass
that makes wear clothing not stand out
that's just about the hanger but what
changed because it's still like that as
far as my yeah with model clothing what
clothing so what changed what changed is
social media
yeah social media there's a lot of but
girls that are just online I had a proud
moment the other day my nine-year-old
we're at a restaurant this lady walked
by and my nine-year-old she pulls that
me and she goes daddy
she's got diaper but cuz that's what I
call it I call it diaper but when those
go
get fake butts because it looks like
they were wearing a full diaper he
doesn't fit your legs that doesn't look
normal she's but she goes daddy she's
got diaper but I was like yes that's
what it is it's diaper but it looks like
a diaper their legs are really scared so
crazy because giant dump in your diaper
like you just [ __ ] your pants and he's
just walking around waiting to get home
it's a mess
but you're right though it's
unobtainable on up typical to obtain
yeah it's also completely exaggerated
right like giant tits small waist
enormous ass giant lips yeah yeah that's
the saddest one cuz that doesn't work no
you look like a fish oh the lip one is
such a bad move and you're ruining the
thing you kiss with it's like your
[ __ ] lips what what is something that
guys do though dad I can't I was
thinking like as if guys did have like
big dick implants there were all every
guy we're doing a dick stretched out but
guys can't have even toupees those guys
can't have like if a guy has like fake
eyebrows girls like what a guy who fake
lips much of a guy got in the gay
community to do it though
yeah yeah yeah there's certain silly gay
guys that get their lips done I've seen
gay guys you're talking to them it's
like super distracting like cuz I like
this okay will they do with the okay lip
injections yeah they're doing the same
thing that a lot of women are doing but
the it's just the lips are weird because
I think people saw that the tits worked
and no one cared like obviously you see
a lot of girls with fake tits and no one
seems to mind and guys think it's kinda
but it did they did mine the first like
three or four everybody would have kind
of make fun of him but now it's like
it's so it's acceptable now what do you
play music what are you doing there's
this video that's been going around I
was gonna ask if this is like a new
thing or just just like the internet got
it but like it's a wigs for men but like
it's gone viral online a few times over
the last few months
oh it's like shaving a guy's head and
then gluing on oh I have seen a wigs you
know sweaty that must be whoa I see so
is it new though or is this sort of just
being redone I don't know and
read a comment because I saw this is
gonna stay see that the thing they're
saying that duh you replace it every six
weeks or something like what happens at
week five tries to grab it your hair
looks like it looks that good Wow
no it's like next-level that's amazing
damn but see me next week before would
it say before what was that before well
show it where it said before because
before
where's before
that's after before would before that
buddy there you go so there's his hair
keep it rolling and it says before oh so
you had some hair oh there's ones that
the person is completely bald and it
looks like that after they're done I've
seen the ones with black dudes I've seen
black dudes get that and it's real weird
like think oh Jesus yeah yeah looking
like that it's a straight-up wig yeah oh
my god how's it look so they shaved his
head let that go let that place stop
moving [ __ ] around look there's like a
highlight videos shows lots of guys
getting this done so you can see lots of
versions I want to see that part we were
just looking at go back to that part we
were just looking at where they're
working on the glue is that out that guy
has one too yeah that's so good oh my
god it's so weird
and then well the stem-cell treatments
that they have for hair loss are very
interesting that [ __ ] is actually
working where they're actually growing
hair back through stem but you have to
have the hair to grow back believe me
that's that that's the misconception a
lot of people have about it if you don't
if you've lost the hair it's all gone if
it's all gone it doesn't come back if
you have a little didn't can yeah that's
a girl's not gonna like that
chrysolite guy's a fake [ __ ] I dated a
girl when I first moved to LA she has
shaved head
she wore wigs all time I didn't give a
[ __ ] but imagine if I just started
wearing wigs everywhere my wife feel
like we doing is my new look things like
this that I've noticed have popped back
up and gotten famous again like they've
already been around the 80s and 90s but
like because people weren't online or it
just didn't go viral in that way
it's snuck back in and people like oh
look at this brand new thing and it's
like it's not new at all
mmm I didn't know this before I didn't
even know women had fake hair - I moved
to LA oh yes do weaves I didn't I knew
nothing about it so first time I looked
at what a girl out here when I first
moved here I went out like you know she
was in bed and I went out to the living
room and I thought it was an animal it
was her hair like I didn't know that
they did that and then I started working
for eat they had a wall full of hair for
all the girls a wall full of hair so
they would like for different girls they
would they had color that matched their
hair yeah each girl had their own like
grow a hair and wouldn't you like when
you're from Texas would you like in
Texas I never saw that and I was just
shocked that it went to that degree I
didn't even know that happen well I
think girls are doing that in Texas too
they just didn't tell you
well that's a common thing that we've no
I I don't think it's what at that time I
don't think no because I think it's more
of a TV thing mmm what's definitely more
of a TV because they're like oh we need
your hair longer you're shorter thicker
and taxes they wouldn't do that yeah
maybe
nah that was weird
[Applause]